bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre cet
après-midi sur notre chaîne la séance de
questions cribles aujourd'hui consacrés
aux énergies renouvelables
c'est delphine batho le ministre de
l'écologie du développement durable et
de l'énergie qui va répondre aux
questions des sénateurs des questions
qui portent notamment sur le prix de
l'éolien sur les conditions d'achat de
l'énergie produite par les installations
hydrauliques ou encore sur le
photovoltaïque le 7 janvier
delphine batho a dévoilé un plan de
relance de la filière photovoltaïque une
filière durement éprouvée c'est durant
ce dernier trimestre par des conditions
économiques difficiles
elle souhaite notamment réaliser 1000
mégawatts de projets solaires en france
cette année ce qui représente le double
de ce qui avait été décidée lors du
grenelle de l'environnement menée par
l'ancienne majorité qui tue donc
direction l'hémicycle pour la séance de
questions cribles sur les énergies
renouvelables
bon après midi à tous sur public sénat
leur nouvelle génération élu en
septembre 2011 on refait la séance les
réactions à chaud des ministres et des
parlementaires alors sortis de
l'hémicycle
tous les vendredis par le moyen de 45
minutes d'actualité politique et
parlementaire
l'europe ce n'est pas que la crise de la
dette et la bureaucratie c'est aussi 500
millions de citoyens que je vous propose
de rencontrer au travers de deux rendez
vous europe hebdo est en quête d'europe
dans déshabillons les jeux des alliés
les politiques et il se déshabille aussi
mais toujours en tout bien tout honneur
alors un lieu une histoire c'est un lieu
un territoire connu ou inconnu là où
c'est écrit l'histoire un lieu
l'histoire ce sont également des hommes
et des femmes
ce qu'ils ont fait cette histoire un
lieu une histoire c'est pour mieux
connaître et mieux comprendre les copies
d'un pays avec également tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui perpétue sa mémoire et
tenerrdis je vous emmène à la rencontre
d'une france inattendue des modes de vie
qui évolue un patrimoine qui se
transforme un regard nouveau sur